Das hier ist mein Sektor. Das hier ist das wichtigste Gerät des Küstenwächters. Das Gerät und das Gerät.
Überlebensradar.
Hallo, hier ist Chaos Radio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 183 am Apparat Tim Pritlove und heute geht's mal wieder rein in die Technik-Ebene. Es soll gehen um Tetra, Tetra-Bündelfunk, ein ja jetzt vielleicht auch nicht mehr so ganz taufrischer Standard, aber gehört jetzt auch nicht unbedingt jetzt zu den Dingen, die man so täglich diskutiert. Aber hier soll es ein Thema sein. Ja, und um das mal ausführlich zu diskutieren, begrüße ich Harald Welte. Hallo.
Vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Wir haben schon gewitzelt. Du bist jetzt hier schon Senior Contributor geworden.
Ja, schön. Ich warte immer noch auf den virtuellen Orden.
Kommt mit der Post. Ja, das ist jetzt schon unsere sechste Sendung hier. Zuletzt haben wir uns über ARM unterhalten. Ich finde, das ist ein ganz gutes Timing. Mittlerweile zeigt sich, was wir da schon vorausgesagt haben, dass es darauf und dran ist, alles zu übernehmen. Ich würde sagen, Intel zittert noch nicht, aber sie haben auf jeden Fall ein Problem.
Naja, doch. Ich würde schon... Aber es geht auch so ein bisschen in beide Richtungen. In den letzten Jahren hat eher ARM gezittert vor Intel, als der ganze Atom, sozusagen, oder das, finde ich, vorgestellt hat, dass das alles kommt mit dem Atom, so wie Intel sich das vorstellt. Aber jetzt ist eher der Spieß umgedreht, ja.
Ja, immer wieder interessant, auch später mal reinzuhören in diese Sendung. Chaos Radio Express 151 war das. Aber wir haben uns auch schon viel über so ähnliche Sachen unterhalten, die wir heute besprechen wollen. Nämlich die ganze Funkerei, jetzt mal von den GSM-Themen abgesehen, vor allem Chaos Radio Express 87 zu nennen, Software Defined Radio. Was ja so ein bisschen der Einstieg war in, wie kann man denn diese ganze Funkerei digital auseinandernehmen und selber auch Software erzeugen, die in der Lage ist, solche Signale auszuwerten. Ja, und heute geht es um Tetra, Terrestrial Trunked Radio, oder auch digitaler Bündelfunk, oder?
Trifft es das? Ja, das ist korrekt.
Was muss man sich darunter vorstellen? Also wir reden jetzt hier eigentlich um etwas, was man benutzt, um miteinander zu funken in der Stadt, mit Funkgeräten rumzulaufen und miteinander zu reden. Das gibt es ja nun auch schon seit Ewigkeiten.
Richtig, ja. Also zunächst gibt es die klassische Analog-Funk-Technik, wo man einfach mit Amplitudenmodulation oder Frequenzmodulation einfachen Systemen auf schmalbandigen Kanälen miteinander spricht und analog die Sprache überträgt. Das ist so ein bisschen wie CB-Funk, nur eben auf anderen Frequenzen. Aber alle Geräte teilen sich eine Frequenz. Jeder, der auf die Sprechkaste drückt, wird dann eben gesendet auf dieser Frequenz und alle anderen Empfang, was der sendet. Das ist die klassische Funk-Technik im Analog-Funk-Bereich. Und da gibt es dann mehrere Evolutionen über sogenannte Bündelfunksysteme, dann ein bisschen zum digitalen Bündelfunk, was Tetra eben ist. Und bei so Bündelfunksystemen ist dann der Unterschied im Wesentlichen zu dem, sag mal, klassischen Sprechfunk, dass es eine Infrastruktur gibt von Basisstationen, die dann Signale verstärken und weiterleiten. Ja, also ein klassischer, wie gesagt, so CB-Funk oder auch PMR oder es gibt ja so diverse, sag ich mal, für den Privatanwender auch käufliche Funkgeräte. Da wird ja immer direkt zwischen den Geräten kommuniziert und wenn jetzt irgendwie die Reichweite überschritten ist des Signals oder da eine Störung ist oder was auch immer, dann kommt das nicht an. Man hat dann relativ bald, ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, wann das geschichtlich passiert ist, aber relativ bald zum Beispiel für Taxifunk, Zentralen oder ähnliches eben Bündelfunkssysteme entwickelt, wo dann die Kommunikation zwischen dem einzelnen Fahrzeug und der Zentrale läuft über eine Basisstation oder mehrere Basisstationen, die diese Signale empfangen und gegebenenfalls, die dann von dort eben weiter verteilt werden auch an andere Teilnehmer in dem System. Auch an andere Frequenzen, ja. Also man kann sich das eigentlich so vorstellen, der einfachste Fall, wie gesagt, alle Funkgeräte funken auf einer Frequenz. Es sollte immer nur einer gleichzeitig die Sprichkaste drücken und eben senden, sonst kommt es zu Überlagerungen. Keinerlei Infrastruktur. Der nächste Schritt sind sogenannte Repeater oder Relays, wo man einfach irgendwo auf einem Dach oder auf einem Berg, auf einem Funkturm eine Station stehen hat, die auf einer Frequenz empfängt und die das in Echtzeit auf einer anderen Frequenz wieder ausstrahlt. Sowas gibt es auch im Amateurfunk-Bereich, solche Relays, sind die relativ beliebt, um eben über einem Berg wegzukommen oder einfach über, sag ich mal...
Aber dabei muss man dann die Frequenz wechseln, weil sonst würde sich das ja gegenseitig stören.
Genau, ja. Also das empfängt auf einer Frequenz und sendet auf einer anderen Frequenz. Und das muss man halt wissen, muss die Frequenzen alle entsprechend einstellen in den Geräten und so. Also eher was, sag ich mal, für Leute, die von der Technik Ahnung haben. Nicht für den normalen Anwender, der so einen Taxifahrer überfordert, dass man dann als tausend Dinge einstellen muss. In der nächste Schutt ist dann eben diese Bündelfunkssysteme, wo man das so ein bisschen automatisiert und wo es nicht diese feste Frequenzumsetzung gibt, sondern wo man einfach dann auch mit Steuerinformationen arbeitet. Also wenn jetzt jemand so die Sprechkaste drückt, dann wird erst mal übertragen, da möchte jetzt jemand sprechen, dann gibt es vielleicht jemanden, der arbitriert, der also sagt, jetzt darf er dann auch sprechen, tatsächlich. Und was das dann umsetzt und gegebenenfalls auf anderen Frequenzen wieder weiter verteilt. Da ist ein bisschen mehr Logik dahinter, ein bisschen mehr Exzegenz.
Also quasi so ein Management der Zuteilung des Frequenzraums, dass man nicht immer sofort sendet, sondern dass man eher erst mal ein ich würde gerne senden Anfrage an das Netz stellt und dann muss einem das Netz das entsprechend zuteilen, wie man das beim Telefonsystem ja eigentlich auch hat, mit ich nehme den Hörer ab, kriege ein Freizeichen.
Ja, das kann eine Funktion von solchen Bündelfunkssystemen sein. Ja, die andere ist eben auch eine dynamische Zuteilung der Ressourcen. Es ist nicht nur tatsächlich dieses, darf ich jetzt, ja ich darf jetzt, diese Anforderungen und Bestätigungen der Kanalzuweisung, sondern einfach auch, dass man je nachdem, was für eine Last gerade ist, dynamisch irgendwelche Frequenzen benutzt oder nicht. Und mal da einen Sender einschaltet oder nicht, also dass einfach eine dynamische Nutzung auch da ist. Und eben auch gegebenenfalls die Verteilung. Also wenn man dann mehrere solche Sendestationen hat, verteilt über ein geographisches Gebiet, beispielsweise über Berlin und jetzt so ein Taxi durch die Gegend fährt, dann muss ja der gegebenenfalls auch auf einer anderen Frequenz lauschen, wenn er in einem anderen Stadtgebiet ist. Und dass solche Sachen halt auch irgendwie kommuniziert und abgestimmt werden und die Geräte sich da dem Netz gegenüber anpassen.
Das heißt, Taxifunk ist heutzutage Bündelfunk?
Ist eigentlich, also es kommt immer drauf an. Natürlich kann jede Taxifirma benutzen, was sie will und was sie irgendwie an Geräten kauft und Lizenzen dafür bekommt von der Bundesnetzagentur. Aber es ist weit verbreitet, da Bündelfunk zu verwenden und zwar schon in der Regel so gemischt analog-digitale Systeme. Hier in Berlin beispielsweise gibt es auch so ein Bündelfunksystem, was von Taxen benutzt wird unter anderem. Mir fällt jetzt gerade der Name nicht ein. Das können wir noch in die Linkliste reinpacken. Da gibt es einen Betreiber. Und das funktioniert eben auch so, dass die eigentliche Sprache wird analog übertragen. Die kann man also nicht digital und nicht verschlüsselt, gar nichts, einfach analog AM-FM. Aber zusätzlich gibt es eben noch so Steuerkanäle, wo dann so, das klingt so wie die alten Modems auf dem Telefon, wo dann mit 1200 BPS in FSK, also Frequency Shift Keying, Informationen noch übertragen werden, digitale Datenpakete. Und das sind dann eben solche Kanalzuweisungsnachrichten oder einfach auch zum Beispiel jedes Mal, wenn jemand die Sendetaste drückt, die Identität dessen, also wer spricht denn jetzt gerade, wird mit übertragen und solche Dinge.
Also so digitale Metadaten quasi und Steuersysteme, so ein bisschen so wie das Bildschirmtext beim Fernsehen mit eingeschleift wurde, ist das dann hier auch noch mit dabei.
Genau.
Aber wie viele Standards gibt es denn jetzt für Bündelfunk? Also ich meine, Bündelfunk, wir reden jetzt erstmal von einem Konzept, was unterschiedliche Ausprägungen hat. Aber welche Standards, gibt es denn überhaupt Standards? Irgendetwas muss es ja geben, also worauf hat man sich denn so am Anfang gestürzt? Was war denn so das?
Es gibt da unterschiedliche Systeme, also teilweise herstellerproprietär, dann muss man halt alle Geräte von dem einen Hersteller kaufen, das fordert den Hersteller, den Kunden meistens weniger, wo einfach nichts standardisiert ist. Ansonsten gibt es sehr viel, was auf diesem, in den 80er Jahren wurde in England von der Office of Communications, sowas wie die Regulierungsbehörde für Post- und Telekommunikation in England, die haben einen Standard herausgegeben, jetzt muss ich MPT 1297 oder irgend sowas, mir ist wie gesagt der Name jetzt gerade...
1327.
1327, ja das klingt gut. Das ist also so ein System, ein Standard, der genauso ein System beschreibt, wie ich es gerade erwähnt habe, also analoge Sprachübertragungen mit nochmal 1200 BPS-Digitalinformationen. Und davon, also von Systemen, die auf diesem Standard basieren, gibt es viele, das ist auch im Wesentlichen das gleiche System, wie es früher mal für diese Pager, diese Skyper, hier sind die glaube ich nicht Skype, Skype ist Telefonie, aber diese Paging-Empfänger, die man hatte...
Scall.
Scall, genau, als man sich noch kein Mobiltelefon leisten konnte, diese Pager-Empfänger mit sich herumgeschleppt hat, genau, solche Sachen, die haben auch dieses System mit benutzt, dann halt rein digital, also nur diese Steuernachrichten mit 1200 BPS, aber ohne analoge Sprachübermittlung. Und da gibt es also eine ganze Menge Hersteller, die Systeme gebaut haben, die sich entweder angelehnt haben oder tatsächlich wörtlich an dieses Speck von Ofcom gehalten haben. Die sind auch heute noch im Einsatz. Das ist auch genau dieser Standard, der in Berlin von diesem Bündelfunknetz verwendet wird.
Scorl war dieses Bündelfunksystem. War das nicht dieses Checker war das eigentliche Bündelfunksystem?
Richtig, richtig, Checker, ja.
Und Scorl war dann quasi nur Paging, der hat sozusagen nur den digitalen Kanal davon mitbenutzt oder was?
Ich bin mir nicht hundertverzentig sicher, ob Scorl jetzt das verwendet hat. Aber Paging-Systeme, wie dieses Checker-System, haben diesen Standard benutzt. Da geht es aber eben nur um dieses Übertragungsformat und nicht um alle Features des Bündelfunksystems. Man hat halt mal spezifiziert, wie übertrage ich da Steuernachrichten mit diesem 2FSK und dann ist das benutzt worden für richtige Bündelfunkanwendungen wie Taxi, aber dann halt auch in einer reduzierten Version für diese Paging-Empfänger. Wie gesagt, das sind noch so analoge Bündelfunksysteme mit ein bisschen digitaler Signalisierung von vorne oder hinten dran und die nächste Evolution ist dann eben digitale Bündelfunkssysteme, wo nichts mehr analog übertragen wird und alles dann digital ist.
Also dieses MPT 1327 kam aus Britannien, wurde hier auch eingesetzt, war aber letztlich nicht das einzige Bündelfunksystem, was zum Einsatz kam und kommt.
Nein, nein, nein. Das ist, sag ich mal, der wahrscheinlich am weitesten verbreitete Standard. Ansonsten gab es eine ganze Menge herstellerproprietäre Lösungen. Diese Netze sind ja keine öffentlichen Netze, wo du Millionen von Telefonnutzern drin hast, sondern das sind oft Bündelfunknetze, die, was weiß ich, von Taxifirmen installiert werden und da sind alle Endgeräte unter deren Konsole und solange die alle das gleiche Gerät kaufen von dem Hersteller, funktioniert das ja. Also es muss ja jetzt nicht nach einer öffentlichen Spezifikation alle die Kommunikation ablaufen.
Also Bündelfunk ist in der Regel immer regional eingeschränkt. Es geht eigentlich immer nur um ein spezielles Gebiet. Bei der Checker war das dann sozusagen deutschlandweit, der Bündelfunk, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, was die für eine Abdeckung hatten. Aber Bündelfunk an sich hat jetzt nicht notwendigerweise die regionale Beschränkung mit drin. Nur in der Praxis wird das eben von Unternehmen mit regionaler Bedeutung benutzt. Also Taxi ist klar. Es gibt eine Taxifirma, die hat eine Taxiflotte in Berlin. Die wird jetzt nicht mit einem Taxi nach München fahren. Vielleicht macht das mal einer, weil er so viel ausgibt, aber dann haben wir keine Netzabdeckung. Ansonsten so Sachen wie, wenn man jetzt über Betriebsfunk z.B. spricht auf irgendwelche Fabriken oder große Chemieanlagen oder Raffinerien, also einfach Industrieinstallationen, die eine gewisse flächige Abdeckung haben, dann will man natürlich in diese Installation, in dem Kraftwerk, in dem Chemiewerk, eine Abdeckung haben. Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu groß oder zu verwinkelt, dass man das mit einer einzigen Antenne abdecken könnte. Also macht man da eben eine Reihe von Basisstationen hin, so ein Bündelfunksystem und kann dann dort kommunizieren. Aber da hat man dann auch wieder durch die Anwendung auf diesem Gelände der Firma eine regionale Beschränkung. Oder teilweise werden auch Funksysteme im Tagebau, in Bergwerken usw. installiert. Das ist dann auch klar, das ist halt nur in diesem Werkwerk.
Also kurz gesagt, Bündelfunk ist so der Versuch, den analogen Sprechfunk zu nehmen und ihm so Features hinzuzufügen, die man so aus dem Telefoniebereich kennt, aber unter Beibehaltung dieses eigentlichen Direktrufs. Das heißt, man kann Gruppen bilden. Man kann Leute auch direkt anfunkten, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Das ist richtig. Also so gängige Features, die einzelnen Systeme unterscheiden sich ein bisschen und die einzelnen Geräte immer, was sie dann unterstützen oder was nicht. Aber generell ist es so, dass es die Unterscheidung gibt zwischen Direktruf. Also wenn ich tatsächlich jetzt, ich möchte mit genau diesem einen Gerät sprechen, weil ich halt weiß, ich möchte jetzt mit dem Menschen, der dieses Gerät in der Hand hat, irgendwie kommunizieren, dann kann ich das machen. Kann also ein einzelnen User, ein einzelnes Gerät adressieren. Dann gibt es Gruppenruf. Das ist dann eher so wie, ich sage mal, klassischer analoger Sprechfunk. Da hat man halt durch unterschiedliche Frequenzen unterschiedliche Gruppen gebildet im normalen analogen Sprechfunk. Beim Bündelfunk wird das halt dann eher als digitale Gruppeninformation mit übertragen.
Das heißt, obwohl ein Gerät das empfängt, stellt es das nicht durch, weil es nicht für ihn ist, etc.
Genau, also jedes Gerät ist halt konfiguriert, dass es in einer bis N Gruppenmitglied ist und bei jeder Nachricht, die vorbeikommt, steht halt vorne dran, das ist jetzt eine Nachricht für Gruppe 10, für Gruppe 15, was auch immer. Und das Gerät stellt es dann entweder durch auf den Lautsprecher, damit es der Anwender hört.
Aber wie verhält sich denn das? Ich meine, da gibt es ja dann, weiß ich, wenn ich in zwei Gruppen Mitglied bin und in beiden Gruppen wird jetzt gerade was hineingesprochen, kriegt dann derjenige, der da gleichzeitig sprechen will, gar keine Sprechbereitschaft oder gibt es da auch irgendwelche zwischen Speicher und verspätet abspiele Funktionalitäten?
Das hängt jetzt wieder davon ab, was es für ein System ist. Es ist eben gerade ein Vorteil der digitalen Bündelfunkssysteme, dass man die Informationen, wenn sie digital übertragen werden, kann man sie leicht speichern und wiedergeben. Und da kommen wir jetzt dann auch langsam in Richtung Tetra. Bei Tetra ist das eben genauso. Da kann dann das Netz einfach diese Sprachinformation puffern in der Basisstation oder irgendwo in einem Netzwerkelement und eben dann mit einer halben Sekunde oder wann auch immer der Kanal wieder frei ist oder eine Sekunde Verspätung wiedergeben und dadurch eben das zeitlich entzerren. Da gibt es dann kein Übersprechen mehr oder keine Störungen.
Aber das wäre jetzt bei dem Analogen auch möglich, weil man ja eigentlich relativ genau weiß, wann die Leute sprechen. Also man kann das ja sozusagen digitalisieren beim Empfang. Und dann wieder analog abzuspielen.
Ich bin jetzt kein ausgewiesener Experte über analoge Bündelfunksysteme, aber ich kann mir technisch durchaus vorstellen, dass es solche Systeme gibt.
Okay, also wissen wir nicht genau, aber klar ist, Bündelfunk ist der Versuch, aus normalem Sprechfunk einen flexibleren Sprechfunk zu machen und eben so diese Bedürfnisse, die man in Gruppenkommunikation hat, insbesondere umso größer diese Gruppe wird, dem entgegenzukommen. Wie zum Beispiel dieses, ich unterscheide verschiedene Personen nach einer Gruppe oder ich unterscheide die Personen als solche und kann sie direkt anfunkten, wie das dann auch immer konkret gelöst ist. Plus eben diese ganzen Metadaten, digitale Metadaten, die noch mit dazukommen, dass ich auch die Möglichkeit habe, am Gerät zu sehen, wer spricht da jetzt eigentlich gerade. Also in beide Richtungen, aber eben alles noch unter der Beibehaltung des eigentlichen Funkfeelings. Tasse drücken, reinsprechen, Tasse loslassen.
Genau, das sogenannte Push-to-Talk.
Gibt es ja auch bei GSM, ne? Also gab es auch so Versuche, das da auch mit reinzubringen.
Nein, das ist dann eigentlich eher VoIP, was man da macht. Also wenn Push-to-Talk über GSM gemacht wird, dann hat man quasi eine Art VoIP-Software, die über eine GPS-Datenverbindung dann dieses Push-to-Talk emuliert. Das ist quasi eine IP-basierte Anwendung ganz weit oben. Also GSM hat da an und für sich nichts direkt damit zu tun. Aber jetzt noch mal, um zurückzukommen auf diese Push-to-Talk. Ja, es ist dann schon so, dass auch in analogen Bündelfunksystemen man dann Features eingebaut hat, um mal einen Telefonanruf irgendwie durchzustellen. Also mit so Vollduplex-Telefonanbindung. Das ist schon auch ein Feature, was gerade im Polizeifunk zum Beispiel, also als Polizeifunk noch analog war und über Bündelfunkssysteme abgewickelt wurde, was da immer mal wieder benutzt wurde oder auch bei anderen Anwendern, dass man irgendwo, dass die Zentrale die Möglichkeit hatte, also der sogenannte Dispatcher, der da irgendwo an einem Arbeitsplatz sitzt und in der Funkzentrale sozusagen sitzt, dass der dann irgendwie einen Telefonanruf machen konnte und den dann durchschalten auf die Funkseite ist. Aber eher die Ausnahme als die Regel, diese Betriebsart. Ja, das war schon auch ein Feature, was benutzt wurde, gerade eben in der Zeit, als noch nicht irgendwie Mobiltelefon so weit verbreitet war. Also diese analogen Bündelfunkssysteme, ich würde mal sagen, die klassisch analogen, das geht mindestens bis in die 70er zurück, wenn ich früher, dass man die irgendwie hatte. Und da war noch nichts mit, ich sag mal, GSM-Mobilfunk, oder dass jetzt jeder Polizist da auch telefonisch erreichbar wäre, der da irgendwo draußen unterwegs ist. Und dann hat man das halt so durchgestellt.
Ja, Polizeifunk hatten wir jetzt noch gar nicht als Beispiel erwähnt, aber das ist eigentlich auch ein ganz klassischer Bündelfunk-Vertreter.
Ja, also immer, wenn man sich so vor, also man stelle sich vor, man lebt in einer Welt, in der es kein Mobiltelefon gibt. Man ignoriert mal den Mobiltelefonaspekt. Und dann schaut man sich an, was gibt es da so für Gruppen, die mobil unterwegs sind, die mit einer Zentrale kommunizieren müssen. Und da gibt es also die Polizei beispielsweise, die Streifenwagen fahren irgendwo draußen rum, müssen mit der Zentrale in Kontakt stehen. Da muss, wenn irgendwo jetzt in der Nähe ein Notruf oder sonst irgendwas kommt, dann müssen die benachrichtigt werden, müssen kommunizieren mit der Zentrale, gegebenenfalls irgendwie Kennzeichenüberprüfungen machen, sonst irgendwelche Sachen, Personenkontrolle, was auch immer. Ja, das ist ein klassischer Anwendungsfall. Rettungsdienste ist ein ähnlicher klassischer Anwendungsfall. Feuerwehr genauso, die sind irgendwo mit Fahrzeugen unterwegs und wollen mit der Zentrale in Kontakt stehen bleiben. Ja, dann gibt es aber auch Taxi. Ja, da sind jetzt überall mit, sagen wir, mit Fahrzeug gebundenen Funkgeräten unterwegs. Dann gibt es Streifenpolizisten, die natürlich irgendwie Geräte am Mann tragen und unterwegs sind, zu Fuß. Es gibt auch den Fall, dass größere Firmen tatsächlich in Städten dann Netze betreiben, zum Beispiel jetzt Stromversorgungsunternehmen, wenn die irgendwo ihre Kräfte unterwegs haben, die irgendwelche Reparaturen vornehmen, dass die mit denen in Verbindung stehen. Und warum geht man da überall davon aus, dass das Mobilfunksystem nicht existiert? Eben weil man will, dass es auch dann funktioniert, wenn der Mobilfunk nicht mehr funktioniert, weil er überlastet ist, weil es einen großflächigen Stromausfall gab, weil wie auch immer. Man möchte eine Infrastruktur haben, die unabhängig vom kommerziellen Mobilfunk ist. Das ist eigentlich der Hintergrund. Ja, ich meine, traditionell hat es den einfach noch nicht gegeben im Mobilfunk wie heute. Da musste man selber was aufbauen. Und heutzutage ist es einfach dieses Feature der Unabhängigkeit von dem kommerziellen Mobilfunk. Weil da kann ja immer mal was irgendwie kaputt gehen. Und gerade jetzt ein Stromversorger, ja, wenn großflächigen Stromausfall ist und dann die Mobilfunk-Basestation, die haben zwar auch öfter so ein bisschen Notstromaggregat dabei oder ähnliches, aber da kann man sich dann nicht darauf verlassen, dass es funktioniert. Da will man lieber seine eigenen Basestationen hinstellen, wo man weiß, da ist ein Dieselgenerator, wo man weiß, die laufen auch wenn der Strom dann irgendwie weg ist. Ja, weil sonst kann man nicht mehr kommunizieren.
Ja, und man muss nicht für jede Minute zahlen, ne?
Ja, das gut. Ja, natürlich zahlt man nicht für jede Minute, aber der Betrieb von so einem Netz, der ist nun auch nicht günstig. Also die ganzen Endgeräte, die speziellen, die teurer sind als irgendwie ein billiges Mobiltelefon. Die Basestationen, die man braucht, die Leitungen, die die Basestation miteinander verbinden, die Standleitungen oder Mikrowellen, Richtfunksstrecken, der Strom, die Unterhaltungskosten der Infrastruktur und auch, nicht zuletzt muss man ja für die Frequenzen auch Lizenzen erwerben bei der Regulierungsbehörde. Ich weiß nicht, wo man da liegt, Größenordnungsmäßig sicher nicht unendlich teuer, aber muss man auch alles zahlen. Also ich bezweifle, dass man, wenn man kein extrem hohes Kommunikationsaufkommen hat, dass man da dann billiger ist als mit kommerziellem Mobilfunk. Also das glaube ich nicht.
Ist also Luxus?
Ist Luxus auf der einen Seite ja, auf der anderen Seite, wie gesagt, ist die Unabhängigkeit, die man will, die Kosten ersparen. Es kann sein, dass es sich rechnet bei großen Firmen. Also wenn ich jetzt, keine Ahnung, der Betreiber des Hamburger Hafens, falls es sowas gibt, oder irgendwie eine Hafengesellschaft, ich weiß nicht, wie das im Detail jetzt funktioniert, organisatorisch, juristisch oder so, aber wenn ich da unglaublich hohes Funk aufkommen habe und das regional sehr beschränkt ist, dann kann es natürlich schon sein, dass ich über die Jahre günstiger bin mit so einer Lösung, als wenn ich jetzt das mit Mobilfunk machen würde. Aber ja, das sind dann so andere Aspekte.
Aber es ist vor allem auch eine ganz andere Kommunikationsform. Man sich bricht die Leute halt direkt an und nicht es klingelt, man muss ran gehen und so weiter, hallo, guten Tag, wer ist da?
Gerade halt diese Gruppenruffunktion, ja, man stelle sich vor, irgendwo Objektschutz-Security-Leute irgendwo in so einer größeren Anlage, der Wachschutz, der da rumläuft, da will man natürlich schon, dass alle dann auf dem gleichen Stand sind mit den Informationen. Wenn da jetzt irgendwas ist, wenn wir sagen, oh, da ist irgendwie, sieht aus, als ob da jemand eingebrochen wäre oder was auch immer. Oder dass alle Leute immer den gleichen Kontext haben. Und deswegen spricht man eben nicht sozusagen Point to Point mit einem Gesprächspartner, sondern hat diesen Gruppenruf. Der IP-vorbelastete Mensch könnte in seinem Vokabular das auch einfach Multicast nennen.
Ja, Sicherheitsdienste, Polizei. Da kommt natürlich dann auch schnell ein anderes Problem mit auf den Tisch, nämlich das Problem der Abhörbarkeit. In dem Moment, wo es halt analoger Sprechfunk ist und sich um ganz normale, ja, AM-FM-Modulationen handelt, da ist es natürlich auch sehr einfach zuzuhören. Polizeifunk abhören ist ja eigentlich so ein verbreiteter Jugendsport und Hackersport.
Gewesen. Gewesen.
Ja, was hat sich denn da, also ich meine, aber das ist natürlich eine Eigenschaft von analogen Bündelfunk und der ist ja auch noch im Einsatz, also wenn man jetzt mit entsprechenden Empfangsgeräten durch die Straßen geht und sich so auf Bündelfunk-Frequenzen einschießt, da kann man dann halt auch zuhören.
Das ist durchaus richtig, ja, also bei den, wie du es sagst, bei dem analogen System ist mehr oder weniger liegt es auf der Hand, dass man da einfach mit einem passenden Empfänger, der auf der passenden Frequenz steht, natürlich mithören kann. Dass man das kann, heißt aber nicht, dass man das auch darf, ja, das ist in Deutschland gibt es also eine ganze Reihe von Paragrafen im StGB und im TKG. Also es gibt jedenfalls einschlägige Strafvorschriften, die das Empfangen von nicht für dich bestimmter Informationen unter Strafe stellen, auch die Weitergabe solcher Informationen und so weiter. Also da ist juristisch ziemlich viel steht da auf dem Papier, was alles passieren kann. Weil man halt wahrscheinlich damals die technischen Möglichkeiten noch nicht hatte, das irgendwie vernünftig abzusichern, hat man einfach die gesetzlichen Warnungen oder die Drohkulisse sehr weit nach oben geschraubt. Ja, und tatsächlich früher beim Polizeifunk, der war ja so ein bisschen unter dem UKW-Hörfunk. Also UKW-Hörfunk fängt bei 87,5 MHz an, wenn ich mich recht entsinne, der untere Ende des UKW-Frequenzbandes und wenn man da so ein bisschen weiter runter den Empfänger gedreht hat, was man früher mechanisch machen konnte, mit den Drehkondensatoren, Spulen, die da im Einsatz waren, dann war man im Polizeifunk drin, der da ein bisschen runter lag. Ja, das war in der Tat auch von Journalisten eine viel genutzte Möglichkeit, um zu hören, wo ist jetzt irgendwie was los, wo fahren wir denn mal hin, um Berichterstattung machen zu können. Ja, das wird in manchen Ländern auch weitgehend toleriert oder akzeptiert. Ich glaube, in Holland ist man da sehr liberal gewesen oder auch immer noch, dass Journalisten so was machen. Also wenn die dann quasi nicht den Polizeikräften ins Gehege kommen vor Ort, war das irgendwie kein Problem. Ich weiß nicht, wie da in Deutschland die Situation ist. Ich stecke da nicht drin. Der, sag ich mal, spontane Ereignisse, Kriminalitätsberichterstattungsindustrie. Ja, aber das ging relativ leicht. Bei den digitalen Systemen ist es halt nicht mehr so leicht. Oder vielleicht noch mit welchen Geräten denn? Also es gibt ja im Funkbereich sogenannte Scanner-Empfänger, die einfach so ein Empfangsgerät, ein bisschen größer als ein Telefon, kann man in die Hand nehmen. Und das kann dann in einem riesigen Frequenzbereich abdecken. Also man kriegt dafür ganz wenig...
Also solche Universal-Empfänger eigentlich, ne?
Genau, Universal-Empfänger. Und da kann ich halt einstellen, auf welche Frequenz soll er empfangen. Man soll er AM oder FM oder Whiteband FM. Und mit 12 Kilohertz oder 25 oder 50 Kilohertz Kanalbreite oder solche Sachen kann man da einstellen. Und dann hört man halt aus dem Lautsprecher, was da gerade kommt. Ja, und im Fall von eben den analogen Systemen kann man einfach mithören. Wie gesagt, ist illegal, aber kann man. Und bei den digitalen Systemen hört man da halt nur Geknatter oder irgendwelche eindeutig digitalen Informationen. Das kann so sein wie bei den, wie früher Modems klungen im Telefonbereich. Das sind eher die älteren Systeme, die neueren, die benutzen dann andere Modulationen, die dann einfach nur nach Lärm klängen. Da können wir auch mal gleich eine Einspielung machen. Also wenn man Tetra empfängt auf so einem analogen Scanner-Empfänger, dann hört man da halt nur so ein Grrrr-Geräusch, was sich wie folgt anhört.
Mal kurz mal rein hören. Alle Einsatzkräfte. Auf dem Kurfürstendamm.
Sehe schon, da ist ein Demodulator und ein digitaler Dekode integriert im Kopf. Es gibt dann. Weil ein Kreis ja 2 Pi sind, gibt es acht Punkte in dem Kreis, wo sich der Phasenzeiger bewegen kann. Nachdem die Übergänge zwischen diesen einzelnen Symbolen nicht auf dem Kreisumfang entlanggehen, sondern zwischen diesen Punkten auf der Kreislinie, gibt es Amplitudenveränderungen und das ist dann dieses Brrrrrr, was man da hört letztlich. Das sind diese Amplitudenschwankungen im Signal, die aber die Information selber nicht beinhalten, sondern das reicht noch nicht aus, also diese Amplitudenschwankungen, sondern man muss sich das Signal ins Ganze ansehen. Da braucht man dann also ein anderes Empfangsgerät. Aber bevor wir da in die Empfangstechnik reingehen, würde ich sagen, sprechen wir dann mal tatsächlich eben über Tetra. Bisher haben wir ja nur Bündelfunkssysteme ganz abstrakt gehandelt.
Also bislang war es so, dass eben nur nach dem reinen analogen Sprechfunk kam dann halt Bündelfunk mit der Möglichkeit, also in dem Moment, wo man halt in der Lage war, zumindest so grundlegend mit digitalen Systemen da so ein System zu managen. Das war dann quasi der Einstieg in den Bündelfunk. Dann wurden die halt immer flexibler. Aber irgendwann gab es dann den Bedarf, auch digital zu werden. Ich meine, was ist der Hauptbedarf? Wahrscheinlich, dass man überhaupt erst mal auch eben das Mithören unterbinden kann. Das war sicherlich ein Antrieb.
Richtig, ja.
Also, dass man da eine Verschlüsselung drauf werfen kann, wie man das bei GSM auch hat. Gerade im Hinblick auf Polizeifunk-Abhören und andere sensitive Geschichten. Es wird aber noch andere Gründe gehabt haben. Einerseits, dass man natürlich dann leichter, also wahrscheinlich besser die Frequenzen nutzen kann, höhere Bandbreiten erzeugen kann. auch einfach flexibler, wenn wir das schon am Anfang so ein bisschen herbeiseniert haben, so mit Zwischenspeicherung etc. einfach flexibler den eigentlichen Sprachaustausch auch organisieren kann und mit anderen Diensten kommunizieren und kombinieren kann.
Richtig. Was halt noch dazu kommt, ist, dass man dann eben nicht nur auf Sprache beschränkt ist, sondern auch andere Daten natürlich übertragen kann. Genauso wie ich mit dem Telefon nicht nur telefonieren kann, sondern eben auch digitale Daten übertragen kann bei digitalen Systemen. Ist das bei Tetra auch so, dass man da also sowas wie SMS zum Beispiel auch erstmalig dann realisieren kann, was vorher eben nicht ging.
Aber es gab ja schon einen digitalen Kanal. Also es war ja nicht so, dass es jetzt vollständig befreit war von so etwas.
Richtig, aber nur mit einer wirklich sehr, sehr geringen Datenrate. Und wenn man jetzt dann mal tatsächlich auch mehr als nur eine SMS übertragen will, sondern wirklich mal so eine IP-Verbindung haben möchte oder so, dann wird es halt mit analogen beziehungsweise so halbhybriden Systemen ist dann auch vorbei. Weil bei 1200 BPS Bruttodatenerrate, da will ich dann kein IP mehr so kommunizieren. Das macht keinen Spaß. Also, naja, ich glaube 1200 BPS IP hat tatsächlich nie jemand wirklich gemacht. Also mal abgesehen von irgendwelchen Freaks. Aber ich meine, IP, ich meine, 1200 BPS, klar. Aber da waren das BWS- und Fido-Netz- und Story-Forwärts. Das ist die Motivation.
Okay, wann kam denn das überhaupt auf?
Tetra ist entwickelt worden in den 90er Jahren. Also, wenn man vielleicht so ein bisschen den Vergleich zu GSM zählt, GSM ist in den 80er Jahren entwickelt worden. Tetra dann eben rund ein Jahrzehnt später. Und es gab eben ganz klar die, die.